[Musique]
quelle est la céréale la plus cultivée
au canada le blé en 2018 les fermiers
canadiens en ont récolté près de 32
millions de tonnes loin devant l'orge et
l'avoine
si le blé est aujourd'hui l'emblème des
prairies canadiennes
il était autrefois très cultivé dans
l'est
c'était même la principale culture de la
nouvelle france à la fin du régime
français le blé était avec les fourrures
l'une des principales exportations de la
colonie sous le régime anglais c'est le
ô canada qui devient la plaque tournante
de la production de blé au bas canada la
présence de maladies et d'insectes et
une mauvaise rotation des cultures font
accélérer l'abandon de cette céréale
mais au 19e siècle le blé s'implante peu
à peu dans l'ouest où il est toujours la
culture dominante
il a toutefois de la compétition le
canola une plante oléagineuse plus
rentable que le blé ça à faire de
l'huile de cuisson du tourteau pour
l'alimentation animale et du
biocarburant
les superficies de cette variété de
colza développé dans les années 70 ont
connu une croissance fulgurante dans
l'ouest et le soleil à un autre les âges
il ne se taille également une place dans
les prairies comme le blé il ya deux
siècles le soya traditionnellement
cultivés dans l'ès part lui aussi à la
conquête de l'ouest